LG and Samsung both unveiled transparent
TV Technologies at CES 2024 with LG
opting for Ola technology and Samsung
showing off how it works with micro LEDs
Samsung's was just a concept demo though
its micro LED did look brighter and more
Vivid than OLED however LG actually had
a functional 77in TV set that will go on
sale later this year we don't know
pricing yet but just keep in mind that
LG's rollable TV from a few years ago
started at $100,000 so yeah how can a
guy never save any money why would you
want a transparent TV LG says you can
place it anywhere like in front of a
window without obstructing The View and
when you want to watch a movie and get a
proper OLED experience you can roll up a
motorized contrast screen that will give
you those Inky blacks and lovely
contrast LG's TV was also paired with
the zeroc connect box which is a
wireless method of transmitting 4K video
and audio to the TV so there are no
wires needed except to plug the TV into
a power outlet